Speaker 1: before we get to today's voicemail
segment. I want to get to a couple of clips of
Mike Pillow as I refer to him or MyPillow CEO
Mike Lindell, the latest conspiracy theory from
Mike Lindell. It's. It's idiotic, it's really a
doozy, but it's an opportunity to remind people
that some much repeated talking points have
long been debunked about the 2020 election.
We're going to look starting with this first clip.
We have a couple of different clips to look at
in this first clip. Mike Pillow says that an eight
hundred and fifty year old person voted in the
2020 election, as well as two thousand people who
were 200 years of age or older. This is dumb for
a few reasons, some of which are obvious, some
of which are less obvious. Let's take a listen.
Speaker 2: Well, I'm going to give an example
today, and I'm not going to say what state
we pulled out. We put from the voter rolls to one
of our team. We have a team that goes through all
of it now with this other system that pulls up
all anomalies. What I mean by that is five people
voting from the same address or five of the
same names. I'll give you an example today
two thousand six hundred and fifty people over
the age of 100. Now you might say, well, well,
that could be it could be two thousand somewhere
over 200, which you like to live in that state.
Round two. OK.
Speaker 1: We'll
tell you what, tell us what state it is, Mike,
Speaker 2: some years old, so. So obviously
one guy was he. They were two hundred
years old. These people there are voting
are 200 years old. Of course, they're obviously
not. They're obviously deceased. But one guy was
eight hundred and fifty years old. OK. And these
are and these are facts. You can get them. You can
get them from your own state state. Now you have
in memory of nonresidents support, but basically
it pulls out all these deviations, anomalies and
they're stacked up like cordwood. And then we
have the camera seats. So then we back it up. So
let's say you have an address like we did like in
Wisconsin. Remember it was twenty three thousand,
Speaker 1: yeah, Wisconsin. Imagine having to be
the co-host or whatever and playing along with
this stuff. It would be great to know the name
of the supposedly 850 year old person and the
state in which they supposedly voted, but sadly,
Mike Pillow doesn't give us that information. Now,
why does this not make sense? So the of course, it
would be fraud. He's not saying that was really an
eight hundred and fifty year old person who voted.
He's saying someone who would be 850 years
old today shows is registered as having voted,
even though we're not aware of people living to
eight hundred and fifty years old. So clearly
it's fraud. I hate to add some facts here, but
when an eight hundred and fifty year old person
would have been alive, the United States didn't
exist. There were no elections. So how would you
register to vote? How did the supposedly
eight hundred and fifty year old person
ever register to vote such that they would
even have been on voter rolls to begin with
when the United States didn't exist, when they
were still alive? It doesn't make any sense. It's
it's pre-Colombian. Incredible. The next clip is
and he was starting to say this when we paused in
the next clip, Mike Pillow's says that 23000 dead
people voted with a specific prison. Everyone use
all 23000 used the same prison address to vote.
Speaker 2: Now you can read Logan if you can
pull up. I'm going to show you guys in
Wisconsin just an example how twenty
three thousand people general voted using a
prison address and use the same phone number
of people, and a lot of them were. We're all
people. We turned out elsewhere as we drove into
it. They don't. They're not alive anymore. They
just use their names, obviously. Right? Yeah.
And they don't live in Wisconsin. Yeah.
Speaker 1: So what's the opportunity here?
The opportunity is to do a real review of
the whole dead people voting thing. This was
extensively looked at. We talked about it in the
aftermath of the election. Michigan was one place
where there were claims dead voters, all these
dead, 10000 dead people voted. Now I encourage
you to check out the BBC article. US Election 2020
The dead voters in Michigan who are still alive.
The BBC started with the 10000 names posted to
Twitter supposedly dead people who voted and
they started investigating some of those and
what they found, what that was, that this was
essentially a combination of people who were just
still alive. The BBC picked 31 of the people,
30 31, and they did 30 names and then added the
oldest person on the list of the thirty one names
people. The supposedly dead BBC spoke to 11
or two, a family member who said, No, no, no,
I'm still alive. They are still alive. For
17 others, there simply was no record of
their death at all. And they found evidence that
they were alive after the alleged date of death.
Three people on the list were dead, and they
looked at those later, I believe they died after
casting their absentee ballot and then in some
cases it was a question of like junior senior
confusion. So this has been widely widely debunked
and it resurfaces in different forms. Now it's the
the names of 23000 dead people were registered
as being at a prison and then voted from there.
Why would anyone do that? Why would if you're
looking to vote in the names of 23000 dead people,
why would you say all of their addresses are a
prison? That would be that would call attention
to what you're doing. You have to believe that
the people who quote stole the election are both.
Incredible criminal geniuses in order
to pull it off. But at the same time,
dumb enough to register 23000 dead voters at the
same address, just none of it makes sense. And
Mike Piller won't stop. And unfortunately,
it's going to be with us for a while